هذا هو السبيل الوحيد الى باخموت
يسمع صوت اطلاق النار طوال الوقت
تحاول موسكو تدمير الطريق المتبقي لعزل
المنطقه المدرعات وسيارات الاسعاف
الاوكرانيه
تعبر هذا الدرب لكن الجنود الاوكرانيين
متشائمين
الوضع صعب جدا بالنسبه لنا يحاول الروس
تطويق ضخمه
نصل هنا الى احد الخنادق التي يستخدمها
الجيش الاوكراني في باخموت للمناوبه بين
المعارك
مكان سري يرتاح فيه الجنود
يتبادلون الاسر
هم متعبون ومتوترون
بينهم من يرتاح
بينما يجهز اخرون خروجهم الى المدينه اي
الى المعارك
عدد الجنود الروس كبير جدا وكانهم مستعمره
لم تتقدم وتدفعون للخلف
من الصعب البقاء احياء والتحمل على
المستوى النفسي
الفريق الطبي يعمل يوميا على اخراج الجرحى
الانهاك الجسدي شديد جدا اما الضغط النفسي
فلا يمكن تحمله اخراج رفاقنا المصابين هو
امر لا يمكن تحمله لكن الاصعب هو عندما
نعود من القتال انه الجحيم هنا عندما نجلس
لنفكر بعض المعركه
يقبع الجنود الاوكرانيون بين فكيك ماشا
الروس يهاجمونهم من الشمال والجنوب والشرق
هذه الكتيبه صورت جزءا من المعارك
المقطع يظهر الجحيم في بخموت
هل سيضطر الاوكرانيون الى التراجع وترك
المنطقه لحمايه انفسهم ما زال الامر غير
واضح